- [Mark] All right, Kathy.
- [Kathy] Yes,
- [Mark] Kathy, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I was born in Los
Angeles, South Central LA,
raised in a single parent home,
even though I have seven other siblings.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- It was very dysfunctional:
government cheese,
free peanut butter,
county check food stamps,
pretty much no attention from anyone.
Ended up in a one-bedroom apartment,
locked in a room all by myself.
- [Mark] You had a mom and dad?
- My dad is doing life, never met him,
and my mother had me at
40, my dad was like 20
and she pretty much didn't
pay any attention to me.
I raised myself, Bill
Cosby in Sesame Street,
pretty much were my parents.
- [Mark] Any traumatic
events in your childhood or?
- Yes, by the age of eight years old,
my stepfather after my mother
would have like five guys over
and herself playing cards,
drinking she'll pass out
and all of the three guys would leave,
but my stepdad would stay
and eventually he started
coming into my bedroom,
I was giving him oral sex pretty much
from the age of eight to
12, he was finger playing me
and then all of a sudden by the time
I was getting ready to turn 13,
he wanted to take my virginity.
So I took my backpack and I left home.
Now, by this time my
mother had already knew,
at the age of nine, she
put a gun to my head
and she said, "Little girl,
what goes on in this
house, stays in his house.
Do you understand?"
So I was very quiet, shy.
I went to school every day
and I'd sit in the front
and I'd be the teacher's pet,
because that's pretty much the
only place I got attention,
was from my school teachers
and maybe some of my other classmates.
And when I am, I never wore skirts.
If I did dresses to
church, only on Sundays
and I'd always wear shorts under my dress.
I was real shy, real smart.
I probably I'm still smart.
I'd make so many dumb mistakes,
because I don't believe in myself
and my self worth is
like still really low.
- [Mark] How did it make you feel,
that your mom didn't believe you
or support you or protect you?
- Pretty much, I found out
like her uncle molested her
when she was a child
and she was born in 1936
and she's Caucasian, an African-American,
and her dad, my German
grandfather, he already had a wife
and he disowned her and,
black and white days.
She pretty much was raised by her uncle
and she was like that.
I come from a dysfunctional
neglected mother,
who raised her children also
in a dysfunctional, neglected situation.
Alcohol was her thing, she
loved alcohol, popping pills
and she was a sex thing, oh my God.
I learned about orgies and drugs and man,
all kinds of like pills
and from beers to hard liquor.
She even let me drink
alcohol in my bottle at two
and also by the time I
was like eight, nine, 10,
I was popping open my own cans of beer.
You could go to the
store, would have a letter
and once the store called
and got it approved,
you could buy beer for your
parents to take it back home.
So now I'm going to school in sixth grade
and I'm buying my own
beers in my own six pack
and sharing them in elementary school.
By the time I was in
junior high, I had DTs.
I had to have a beer every
day before I go to class
and pretty much before I went to bed.
I still drink to this day.
Leaving home at 13, I got hooked up
with this gang called 8-Tray Hoovers
off of Manchester and Hoover,
and I really found love.
A lot of guys show me a lot of attention,
embraced me and treated me
like I was their little
sister, a family I never had
and so went from stealing,
even though I stayed in school,
still making good grades
but ditching and partying
from drinking to weed smoking, PCP,
I'm pregnant at 16 and at 12th grade,
graduated from high school,
accepted into a four-year university
at Cal State Dominguez Hills.
I had been working at
Jack in the Box from 14,
I had my on own apartment
by the time I was 18,
working two jobs, going to college
and I have the same problem,
dysfunctional baby daddies.
So now I'm a single parent
at the age of 23, from snorting cocaine,
already popping ecstasy pills,
pretty much curiosity of the
cat, thank God I'm still here.
I might probably be living on my eighth
or ninth live by now but uuhm...
- [Mark] So what is your drug today?
- Today, I still drink,
light some marijuana,
crack, I started smoking
crack at age 23, 43,
so 20 year history.
I was a real crack head
when I started off,
the first 10 years and
then I became a rockstar,
but the drugs are so terrible today,
you won't even get no
cocaine in the crack.
So all of it is whack so,
I drink every now and then.
I went to prison, been in and out of jail
from eight to 30, 35 years
old, hit Chowchilla three years
and wow, that was not so cool.
It's very scary, frightening.
I met some lifers
and told me you got
another chance to make it.
So these last seven years
I've been out of prison, still downtown.
Honestly, I had an
apartment and had a man,
but he was controlling, he's a Muslim,
he wanted me to do everything his way,
he used to beat me and
I thought it was luck,
'cause he showed me attention tho'
and that's what I've never had, right?
That's all I wanted was
somebody to really love me
and then I found out he was sleeping
with my 25 year old daughter.
Oh yeah, so I had the child of a girl,
September 11 she'll be 26 this year
and then 11 months later I had a son,
they're not even a year apart,
two different baby daddies.
Yeah, because the first one was no good
and so I have two that's
like almost in the same age,
in a year, next week my son will be 25
and my daughter is still 25,
but they're not twins, right?
Then I have a 22 year old.
Well because crack became my
life, my friend, my buddy,
after the separation of my
second children's father,
'cause I realized he put
his mother before everything
and I couldn't stand it
'cause I hated my mother.
So how could you love
your mother more than me?
And so, I walked out, left
him this youngest two kids.
My oldest went to my sister in 1999.
Woo party like a rockstar
downtown LA Skid Row,
and I'm the prettiest thing downtown,
so they say, huh.
Man, I get hooked up with
biggest, dope dealers down here.
I don't even have to do too much,
but pretty much be pretty and smoke.
Well, the party never ended.
It's like a nightmare,
how could this girl, me,
straight As student, so smart,
I even speak nine languages,
I can say, (foreign language)
(foreign language)
I speak a little Arabic (foreign
language), sign language
and it's like, (sighs)
"Where did all my wanting
to be a school teacher
dreams go?",
I woulda loved to help others,
maybe be the first woman
president who knows, right?
Well, I don't know,
things happens when...
then you begin to get
by you become bipolar
and then I find out I got
mental issues and PTSD and ADHD.
You see, I can't really stop moving,
I can't be still, too much
and I take my meds, I go to counseling,
I'm just lost and I'm still
downtown LA, the city of hope.
Well, I hope one day,
I can find the true me.
I don't know, drugs, cigarettes,
that's why I been smoking
cigarettes since I was 18,
still smoking cigarettes,
kinda nasty, ugly call people.
I'm like, "It's not Corona".(coughs)
You know, please, if I don't
have Corona, thank God.
- [Mark] What was the
lowest point of your life?
- The lowest point of
my life is pretty much
I went to prison,
left home at 14 and never
went back home to mom.
My mother passed away
and
as much as I hated her, she
was my best friend,(crying)
because anytime I did time
she would still be there.
You know, right now,
after seven years of getting out of prison
and living with this man,
all my stuff is in storage,
'cause I had an apartment
but after I realized
that him and my daughter was together.
I went into a program, got clean
and stayed off everything
for about six months.
Social security, my income
got cut off last year
and I'm back here, I'm
homeless again, without a gee.
I've been downtown, you know
I could say I been down here,
about 20 years, it has been 20 years.
I'll be 44 in two months
and I don't know, (wails)
sometimes I wish I had,
I don't have any STDs.
I still get things.
I'm computer illiterate, computer phobia.
Everything's on computer,
I don't know what to do.
I wanted to be an actress,
but Illuminati and sacrificing people
and I don't know, I don't wear makeup.
- [Mark] Where do you live now?
- Now I stay wherever
I, just people stay at,
where I fall asleep.
I been down here so other
people have (indistinct),
invite me over to their holes.
- [Mark] What are you doing for money?
- For money?
I recycle
I lost all my wallet, everything
and it's just like I gotta start all over,
everything's closed.
It's like right now, I'm
at the bottom of my bottom
and I don't know how to get out.
I really don't know how to get out.
To be a domestic violence
victim,
you would think I should
be able to get some help,
but all lines be busy,
"Oh, come back",
"Gotta have ID".
It's just like, I don't
know where to start.
It's like, I'm just
walking, I'm not exist...
I'm just existing, I'm not living life,
but I'm afraid I'll kill myself,
I have three children,
my 22 year old, she's an
officer somewhere in Ontario.
She know I don't like police,
but then the police saved me
and rescued me from myself.
My son, he's a criminal
like me five years,
two strikes in prison,
he'd be 25 in a week.
My 25 year old, the one that's
slept with my ex boyfriend,
come to find out she's schizophrenic
and she's hooked on crystal meth
and I don't know where she is.
So pretty much, that's where I'm at today.
I bathe in a bucket, get some
water from water hydrant.
- [Mark] What's the worst thing
about living on the street like this?
- [Kathy] I can't stand the rats
and these rats are bigger
than I am. (giggles)
Pretty much the rats, I've
never been afraid of people,
'cause I've been in the
streets since I was 13.
Yeah it's the rats. (giggles),
and also the Corona virus.
I had shelter, I was in a
place almost seven years,
from program for a year,
to having a single,
to having a one bedroom,
with a key (sniffles)
and now I don't even have my
storage key 'cause I lost it.
My mother ashes in there and
I own like right now, $87
on my storage and I can't even pay that.
- [Mark] Where do you think
you'll be in five, 10 years?
- Hopefully not dead if
Corona don't get me first
and the positive side,
working on maybe going to
Tarzana Treatment Center,
I don't know.
You know, seven years I
haven't been back to prison
never been back to jail.
My record got expunged,
I could get my prison
record dropped and expunged,
and then three years I could seal the deal
and I'll be a new person.
- [Mark] What stops
you from getting a job?
- I was working at Walmart and part time,
I stop myself pretty much
and I need ID, need social security card,
which is all the things that I need to do,
that I pretty much, it's like,
I don't have any, ah,
to even start all over.
How many times have I started over?
I don't know what to do,(sniffles)
I don't have any help.
You would think out of my mother's,
well, one of them is my
sister and my brother
so kinda make about four
other sisters I have,
maybe
five, no four,
you would think maybe they would wonder
where they little baby sister
is and how she's doing?
They never cared when I was born anyway.
(sniffles)
My street family knows me
more than my biological family
and I'm still trying to find myself.
I wish I could work
with like Oprah Winfrey
or Michelle Obama, even Hillary Clinton.
I mean, honestly, to really
wanna continue my life,
to go into politics and
change The White House,
to We The People House,
paint it every color of the rainbow
because I don't see
color when I see people,
I would not want to be the president.
I want to go into the
judicial legislation part,
I want to rewrite, change and create,
recreate a newer world order
for the good of mankind.
Every child bar should have food, shelter,
clothing, education,
immunization, all over the world.
What is wrong with you people
who don't really love yourself?
I love myself, but I hurt
myself and self sabotage myself,
because pain, it eases everything
that I'm going through,
but I don't do my best,
I've never done my best.
If I do my best,
maybe I'll be a millionaire.
Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you so much.
(Kathy sniffles)
- (crying)
You're welcome.